[Music]
let's go down to the 512 in Austin Texas
and talk to Heather what's up
Heather hello heyo what's up um so my
question is should I move past my trauma
to make my family more
comfortable I don't even know what your
trauma is and the answer is back story I
don't know if you know what it is but
your the answer to your question is
no no I don't even know what happened I
don't even care what happened yeah but
the answer is no now tell me what
happened okay so um my mom married my
stepdad when I was in like fifth grade I
guess and we were extremely close to me
and my stepdad and then um once I hit
puberty things started to get weird um
you know he would make comments about
different things and it slowly kept
escalating to the point where he would
text me strange things um you're being
very vague talk talk talk me through it
yeah so he he texted me when I was 15 I
you know as a 15-year-old girl I wanted
to drive to school the next day I didn't
even have a license so I went in my room
throwing in a tantrum as teenage girls
do and he texted me and said if you send
me a video I will let you drive to
school and I immediately was like what
are you talking about and he said never
mind delete this text message don't tell
anyone well I you know went to my school
counselor the next day good for you and
um they called my mom in and apparent I
don't remember any of that like my brain
is blocked it out um but my sisters told
me that they had to sit down with him my
stepdad and he said he was crying you
know and he said he would get counseling
all these different things and he never
did um
and then it just you know he started he
hid video cameras and he tried to get
pictures of me from under the doors and
stuff as I'm getting into the shower and
different
things um and so for the last I would
say five years I've had zero contact
with him um I wrote him a long letter
and let him know you know I know you did
all of these things the whole family
knows you've done all these things and
you're no longer welcome at family
events and so everybody's kind of stuck
with that everyone was fine with it hold
on Heather Heather Heather why isn't he
in
jail I never press my mom's still
married to him so it's dude complicated
situation yeah well hold
on your feelings and your your driving
what happens next that's complicated and
hard okay and I'll honor that to the to
the end of time
M it is not complicated because your mom
chose a child molester and a sex
offender over her
children that is not why it's
complicated yeah
okay yeah you as I you know as well as I
do that going through like just that
conversation that you don't aren't even
able to remember would tell both of us
that going to court and going through
all the drama and getting put on this
stand all that stuff would be really
really
tough and if you choose to not go
through that that's your choice to make
as the person who experienced
this but your mom made her
choice yeah and it disgusts me to know I
cannot even wrap my head around it you
know why because I got a seven-year-old
little
girl and I'll burn the world down for
her
yeah
yeah and listen listen you deserved that
and I'm sorry that
happened yeah my mom has her own set of
issues like she's an alcoholic and um
bipolar and all sorts of things I know
that's not an excuse don't care don't
care I don't care you deserved a mom
that would fight for you till the end of
time you don't have that yeah you
deserved a dad that would have stuck
around and you deserved a stepdad that
would honor you like his
own my so my biological father is in the
picture he was a truck driver so I think
that's why I clung so close to my
stepdad because it was the first time I
had like a father figure consistently
there every day you
know um and I didn't my real dad had no
idea any of this was going on until I
was 23 I told
him like he had no
clue
geez so um but so fast forward to July
of this year my grandmother passed away
and my mom asked if my stepdad could
come to the funeral to support
her um and I was you know already
distraught from losing my grandmother so
I told her I don't care I just don't
want him to talk to me I don't want him
sitting next to me I but I don't care if
he's there and that went fine
surprisingly um it didn't bother me I
don't know if I was just in shock or
what um so I guess the rest of the
family took that as like I'm over it and
now he can be invited to Thanksgiving
and weddings and Christmas and different
things like that um and uh honestly feel
like I kind of fell for it because I was
having a conversation with my husband
and we have two k two kids
ourselves and I was like telling him I
didn't care if he was there and he's
arguing you know well our kids aren't
going to be around him and I almost felt
like I was defending my stepdad because
my family wants him back at these family
events and I just don't know how to
handle that can I pretend you were my
can I pretend you were like my best
friend yeah or my sister actually' be
different if it was you were my sister
M I would tell you to never go around my
family ever again ever
and if you've ever listened to this show
for any length of time you know I've
never said those words until just now
yeah but not a single one of your family
members that you've described on your
side of your family deserves to be in
the same universe is
you
yeah of course that guy's on his best
behavior you know why he should be in
jail yeah and that's you know what my
sister was saying she's like uh you know
it's not like he's ever going to be
alone with the kid like everyone's G to
be watching him like a HW it doesn't ma
it doesn't matter yeah yeah it doesn't
matter it as well okay it doesn't
matter okay you're not the crazy one Hey
listen the fact that you said in this
call um that somehow you messed
something I must have been you know
grieving
yes you didn't do anything wrong
yeah yeah you didn't do anything
wrong
and you can do a lot right moving
forward I don't know that I I'm not
hearing in your story that you've ever
properly
grieved the fact that your mother sided
with a
um
disgusting disgusting ing human being
over her
daughter yeah I haven't I've always been
a mommy's girl and I've always been the
person that stands up for her bad
actions and so trauma you've probably
heard this the fight or flight you've
heard that before yeah have you heard
freeze uh no okay there's fight flight
or freeze but there's a fourth one that
is not talked about very
often it's called Fawn F A
WN mhm it's when people hurt us so
bad that we keep ourselves safe by
nuzzling up really really close to the
person who keeps hurting
us that makes a lot of sense maybe
they'll stop I can't defeat them or I
won't punch them I can't get out of them
because out of this relationship because
it would be too
painful but I'm going to take action my
body hasn't shut me down I'm just Frozen
yeah I'm going to get as close as
humanly possible and make sure
everything's perfect so they I won't
become a target of their
evil
yeah you got it's it's time it's time to
be absolutely done with them I'm so
grossed out and disgusted for you
Heather I'm so
sorry yeah I
think I don't I just don't know how to
here's how here's how how I tell my
family you know that in all honesty
Heather they
don't gosh I'm I'm going against
everything I almost say always they
don't get an
explanation yeah here's what I would how
I would say it and I'd be very clear I
would write a letter dear
Mom and if sister's involved too whoever
saying like well you know it's going to
be okay because we're
gonna yeah I was one of my told me that
he's not a sexist Defender because he
never physically touched
me oh
man
yeah your sister's
wrong yeah and so here's what the letter
would say dear fill in the blank and I
would name them
all for multiple years this man took
advantage of me sexually in my own
home I reported it and the only adults
that stood by me were school
officials and when it continued to
happen my body shut
down because nobody was coming to
help I've been very clear over the years
that this man is not welcome in my life
at family functions family
events I mistakenly allowed him to
attend a funeral in support of my mom
and suddenly that has become permission
it was seen as permission for him to
show up
everywhere
MH as such I will no longer be attending
any and all family functions period I
wish yall the best
Heather yeah and listen that's
it if you are my best friend I would
tell you to block them and delete them
from your
phone yeah they have walked away from
you in a really grotesque
way yeah and then I want you to write a
letter to 13-year-old
Heather and tell her I'm so sorry that
no adult came to help
you and let 13-year-old Heather know
that that crap stops with you because
you're going to defend your daughters
you're going to believe your
daughters and somebody will break your
daughter's heart somebody will hurt your
daughters that's the nature of the
game but you will never turn your back
on on them like it happened to
you yeah
fair fair very
fair have you talked to somebody over
the years about
this I have not it's
time
yeah it's time can I tell you why how
old are your
daughters uh my daughter is eight and I
also have a son who four
okay have you started getting super
hypervigilant
very I mean my husband I watch him like
a hawk and he's an angel he would never
do anything have you ever heard me talk
about GPS pins
before I don't believe so okay you ever
sent somebody a location like where are
you and you just send them a quick GPS
pin yeah okay your body does that
too and your body put a GPS pin in men
left alone with little girls
because you were taking advantage of of
of by one for a long
time yeah in a number of different ways
and a number of different
places your brain knows that when a man
is around nowhere is safe not even the
shower not even the bathroom not even in
your
bedroom not even your
phone yeah and so it's in
discriminate every time you see a grown
man with a little girl your body sounds
the alarm
system yeah and that's what that
hypervigilance
is I'm going to tell you something
really hard okay okay most people stop
the conversation here because they're so
terrified of this thing called victim
shaming
okay I'm not blaming you for one thing
that happened what happened to you was
evil and wrong and hellacious and I hate
the fact that no adults came to rest
rescue you cuz that was their job yeah
and your husband doesn't deserve to be
treated like a predator in his own home
Fair very fair yes that means it's your
work to
do and we want our daughters mine and
yours we want them to be aware and
understanding but we don't want them to
live in Terror like you've had to live
the last 20 something years of your life
Fair very fair it's time for you to go
talk to somebody this is your work to do
okay yeah okay will you commit to that I
will you
promise yes you deserve to Exhale for
the first time in 25
years yeah you deserve to sleep all
night for the first time in 25 years and
you don't sleep I know you don't yeah I
don't sleep you know why because your
body would be failing you if it let you
sleep because there's a man in the house
with a young
girl yeah
right and it's time for you to let that
13-year-old girl go be a knuckleheaded
13-year-old girl Let Her Go be 15 and
throw temper tantrums in a
room right right
yeah yeah for sure and let's let your
husband have deep really close connected
relationship with his young
daughter they both desperately need
that yeah
right yes okay
what you're doing you are changing your
family tree and you're cutting ties with
evil yeah and you know as well as I do
they're going to guilt trip you they're
going to drag you back into the fold so
I would cut all ties I would delete them
out of my phone they have cashed out
they chose a sexual predator over their
daughter or their
sister and if I were you I would spend
weeks weeping over that like
devastated
and then we're going to figure out what
comes next because that's the that's the
world that's the cards you were dealt
unfortunately
yeah Fair very fair thank you so much
for all of your advice no thank you for
being honest and your question as we
started this thing do I need to cash
out I'm having to take a deep breath
hold
on I just
h
no you never have to swallow your trauma
so that other members of your family can
go on with their little fantasy
land if an adult chooses to stay with
somebody who hits
you who leaves you who sexually abuses
you and that person's your mom and that
person's your husband or your person
your dad they're
out they have looked at you and said I
don't want to be in relationship with
you in a real
world I'm choosing evil over
you and they're going to try to make it
your fault walk
away I'm telling youall as a community
we got to start taking care of our kids
because the ROI on not taking care of
them and this culture of abuse and this
culture of don't tell anybody and this
culture
of the insane amount of sexual abuse
that goes on with adults and kids that
goes un reported that goes
unprosecuted that goes un oh he didn't
mean it he's actually a good is
staggering and you know how I know
because I've sat with these women for
decades
and until the adults in the world start
coming to the rescue of these
kids and not protecting
evil we will have hell to pay and we'll
deserve every single bit of
it